welcome to the Matt Walsh show everybody
thanks for being here thanks for tuning
in and listening remember to subscribe
on itunes to get the entire show or
become a premium member of the daily
wire so this situation in Virginia is
pretty remarkable we've got we've got
the governor with his black face photo
the Lieutenant Governor accused of
sexual assault and now the Attorney
General who's third in line in the line
of succession mark herring is admitting
that he also wore black face when he
when he was a when he was a teenager he
dressed as a rapper for Halloween when
he was 19 and he wore he wore brown
makeup as he put it or as as one of that
one of the newspapers out of one of the
one of the great and very honest I think
was in New York Times their headline was
that Haring wool wore dark makeup and
then they had to change it to black face
I've they were trying to get around
having to say that he wore black face so
what makes what makes this revelation
about Haring so incredible is that
Haring had called on Northam to resign
only a few days ago I think it was on
Sunday that he was saying Northam should
resign for wearing blackface and what he
knew while he was saying that that there
was that he had done the same thing and
that there's probably a photo of it
somewhere which is which will be the
only reason why he's admitting it now is
if there's a photo and actually we have
a fourth Democrat caught up in a scandal
as well Virginia Democratic congressman
Bobby Scott reportedly was told about
the sexual assault accusations about
just in Fairfax he was told by the
accuser herself more than a year ago but
he said nothing and he did nothing which
you may recall when this when all this
information first came out well also
about Northam I you know it's it's it
seems clear to me that there's no way
this the photo of Northam there's no way
that nobody knew about that it seems
unlikely that the media had never run
across that photo before and and with
these accusations about Fairfax it also
seems
unlikely that Bobby Scott is the only
person who knew beforehand I think we're
gonna find out that a lot of people knew
about it but just decided not to say
anything by the way according to other
reports just in Fairfax when discussing
these accusations with his aides said in
reference to the to the alleged victim
he said f that B word only he used the
actual words now and I don't know if he
said them not these are according to
people close to him that he said this to
you know one of them has turned around
and told the media can you imagine if
there was a report of Cavanaugh using
that language about about Christine Ford
can you imagine and as for the
accusations the accuser Vanessa Tyson
has gone public over the last few days
she's given more details about the
alleged attack and her story hasn't
hasn't changed she remembers everything
vividly she remembers the date the
location everything else now I'm not you
know I still am not prepared to say that
Fairfax is guilty I'm not saying that
and we could never really say that for
sure unless you know there are only two
human beings on earth who will really
ever know exactly what actually happened
in that hotel room so we can never say
for sure but we can look at these
stories and based on the information
available we can decide if the
accusations seem reasonably credible or
not you know those that's that's about
as far as we can really go we can never
disprove or prove it or know for sure
but we can decide this seems credible
this does not seem credible
so with Kavanaugh again for that
comparison I felt that the accusations
were not credible because of the lack of
details she didn't know the date or
location or story kept changing she
claims she had evidence and proved that
she never she refused to actually offer
up for people to see such as her
therapist notes which is kind of
suspicious and the circumstances under
which these accusations came to light
were all
suspicious this was a Liberal Democrat
woman accusing a Republican appointed
Supreme Court justice so that doesn't
mean that she was lying but we do have
to factor in that there would be we have
to admit an incentive a political
ideological incentive to lie or
exaggerate or whatever or maybe half
intentionally misremember or whatever
the case now on the other end of the
spectrum I've always thought that the
accusations against Bill Clinton there's
an example perfect example of what again
although we don't know for sure this
perfect example of what very credible
allegations look like because in that
case based on the information we have
very credible the accuser Juanita
Broderick accused Bill Clinton of of
raping her back in I think the late 70s
she knew the exact date the exact
location of the attack she was found
bloodied and crying moments after this
posin attack occurred she told people
about it back then and she is or she was
anyway I don't know if she still is a
Democrat so there's no political
incentive to make this up all of the
details in that case lined up in her
corner every single one there was really
not there was no there's no detail of
that situation of that case that lines
up in Clinton's corner to make him look
innocent so with the Fairfax stuff we
have to ask is it more on the Kavanagh
end of the spectrum or is it more on the
Clinton end of the spectrum it and I
would say it's sort of in-between it
maybe leans a little bit more towards
Clinton because after all the accuser
not only has all these details but she
has no obvious incentive to lie she's a
Democrat herself she met Fairfax at the
Democratic convention so she's not only
a Democrat but she's a apparently is or
was a politically involved Democrat not
to mention she told people about this a
year ago before this stuff what the
governor was happening before Fairfax
was in the news so why would she make up
this story a year ago about a member of
her own part
and why would she report it to members
of the Virginia congressional delegation
if it weren't true we have to ask is it
more likely that she made this up this
lie about a democratic politician as a
Democrat herself or is it more likely
that it happened well I don't know but I
think maybe it leans a little bit in
that direction so overall it's a mess in
Virginia and and let's remember this is
the important thing let's remember where
this all started okay and let's not lose
sight of this this all began this all
happened because the Democrats try in
that state tried to legalize late term
abortion Cathy Tran and her bill
legalizing abortion up to birth that's
why this is happening if it weren't for
that this would not have happened if she
doesn't push that bill then she isn't on
video defending 3rd trimester abortions
and then Northam isn't asked about it on
air and then he doesn't go off on this
whole disgusting thing about killing
babies after birth and then the rest of
the stuff doesn't happen so this is a
what we're seeing right now this is this
is a rare instance of swift and clear
and cosmic justice unfolding right in
front of us these people tried to
legalize and fantasize and now they are
self-destructing because of it this is
so we should we should appreciate that
you know what we're seeing because they
richly richly deserve this not just
because of the infanticide support
although that's enough in and of itself
but also because of the hypocrisy and a
double standard because that's the thing
with this all things being equal as I've
been saying I don't think a person
should be forced to resign in disgrace
because of an inappropriate costume they
wore 30 years ago you know but in this
case I think Northam needs to resign
anyway because he supports killing
babies after birth so that's enough
reason for him to resign so I'm happy
with that if he resigns because of that
or if he was
for another reason than as far as I'm
concerned that's justice anyway and so
if the blackface thing is what takes him
down then fine and then herring the
Attorney General if he had just kept his
mouth shut over the weekend or if he had
come out and defended Northam and said
you know you know what maybe we should
then it would be one thing but he came
out and called for Northam to resign so
it seems to me although usually I would
say okay he wore this costume when he
was 19 he was dressing up as a rapper
back in whatever the 70s or 80s you know
who cares so let's move on but this is
the standard that he set he's the one
who apparently thinks this is what he
said over the weekend if you do that
then you should resign so he should be
held to that same standard so that's all
you know and it's a little bit of it's a
little bit of a precarious thing because
you know I'm afraid what we're gonna end
up with here is it's it's gonna be it
basically what we're entering into
something it's gonna be like the me2
movement except with blackface and I
tell you right now I we all know what
journalists are doing there is an army
of journalists right now who are
scouring yearbooks and and the internet
and they're you know probably rifling
through garbage cans and trash dumps
searching desperately for blackface
photos of Republicans that's what they
really want and you know something
they'll probably find some and so now
we're gonna have this whole blackface
crisis where anyone who's ever worn
blackface it's gonna be thrown out there
and then we're gonna have this whole
thing and I don't think it should turn
out it should turn into that I think
that would be kind of ridiculous
obviously wearing black faces there is a
bad thing you shouldn't do it everyone
agrees with that no one's defending it
no one thinks it's okay there are many
other kinds of inappropriate costumes
people could wear there are many other
obnoxious and wrong and despicable
things people can do when they're young
and have done and as far as ranking the
kind of like bad things people might do
when they're in their teenage years or
their early 20s wearing blackface is
well
certainly not the worst thing we'll put
it that put it that way it's not
necessarily at the top of that list
right so I don't think it should turn
into a whole hysteria or crisis but just
some trying to balance that with the
fact that I do think that these Virginia
Democrats deserve everything that's
coming to them because of the
infanticide but also because of their
own double standards its herring is now
getting lumped on top of that but he's
getting lumped in with this that's his
fault he's the one who came out and said
well he needs to resign over this
speaking of double standards let's take
a look at this here is Joy Behar of the
view in 2016 watch this clip right here
the New York Times they had an op-ed
piece in praise of naturally curly hair
they say that it's making a comeback
when it's like I've always had curly
that is all day in a statement huh oh
thank you oh you know this picture now I
know
I was joy I was so cute I was we are you
is Goodyear is a circle at 29 it was a
Halloween party I went as a beautiful
African woman oh yes you ain't black
daddy the BPM it is really weird I
thought that was I thought that is me do
you have tanning lotion on I don't know
my had makeup that was a little bit
longer than my that's my actual hand so
okay so now we have another Democrat in
blackface it really is I mean these
people just can't help themselves can
they it's it's pretty incredible so
there she is it admitting to wearing
blackface and once again it's it's the
double standard because taking that in
isolation and you look at that you see
the photo and you think okay whatever so
she wore that costume a long time ago
who cares except wasn't Megan Megan
Kelly was fired from her job because she
asked a question about about blackface
hypothetically let's let's remember that
Megan Kelly now so Ralph Northam war
blackface he has not resigned he still
has his job the Attorney General still
has his job as of right now even though
he wore blackface Joy Behar or blackface
has her job megyn kelly asked a question
about blackface she said remember she
said on her show well what if somebody
you know wore black face and they meant
it in a you know in to pay tribute to I
think it's an example she gave
hypothetically is what if somebody went
out for Halloween dressed as Diana Ross
and they wore you know they darken their
skin but they meant it as a tribute it
was not mocking and so it's a
hypothetical question she was raising
and she lost her job over that meanwhile
you have these Liberal Democrats who
actually wore black face and they all
still have their
that double standard is a little bit
hard to stomach
speaking of double standards we should
mention this as well double standards
and hypocrisy and blackface in effect
Elizabeth Warren it turns out claimed
that she was Native American she claims
you well we know that she's been
claiming she's Native American but she
also put it down on a 1986 registration
card for the Texas State Bar so now this
becomes more serious this isn't just
some claim that she's been making you
know verbally as a politician trying to
play the identity politics game no she's
been putting it down on documentation
she claimed on this registration card
for the Texas State Bar that she was
Native American
now she's again trying to explain
herself and here she is answering
questions about this latest revelation
here it is I am NOT a tribal citizen I
had a good conversation last week with
chief Baker who's chief of the Cherokee
tribes and I told chief Baker that I am
sorry that I extended confusion about
tribal citizenship and tribal
sovereignty and for harm caused I am
also sorry for not being more mindful of
this decades ago tribes and only tribes
determined tribal citizenship I had a
good conversation with chief Baker he
was very gracious and we continued to
talk about issues and continue to work
on issues that matter deeply to Indian
country and continue to work on things
that we both care a lot about nothing
about my background ever had anything to
do with any job I got in any place it's
been fully documented and there's no
evidence
this was about 30 years ago and I am NOT
a tribal citizen tribes and only tribes
determine citizenship when I was growing
up in Oklahoma I learned about my family
the same way most people do my brothers
and I learned from our mom and our dad
and our brothers and our sisters and
those were our family stories but that
said there really is an important
distinction of tribal citizenship I am
NOT a member of a tribe and I have
apologized for not being more sensitive
to that distinction it's an important
distinction okay so you know your
campaign for president is is is not
going well when you have to make
statements like I am NOT a tribal
citizen when you have to clarify that
repeatedly in the same interview and say
that you're not a tribal citizen that
you know it's not a good sign once again
with this though all things being equal
I would almost be tempted to say well
okay you know maybe she was she was told
by her parents that she's Native
American and she believed them you know
and she put it down on under on this
documentation maybe she wasn't trying to
commit any kind of fraud it was really
just a mistake or she she didn't know
maybe I'd be tempted to have some
leniency and to be understanding but the
problem is that elizabeth warren is a
promoter of spreader of disciple of
identity politics and if anyone else any
republican had done this she would eat
them alive and we all know that cultural
appropriation is a cardinal sin on the
left and warren would happily destroy
anyone else's life over it so now she's
being hoisted on her own petard as they
say and are we supposed to swoop in and
say no no no don't let her take that
dose of her own medicine
don't let her standards don't you know
let's not force her to live up to our
own standards I'm not gonna say that you
should have to live up to the standards
you said all right so there's a it's
just a big mess for the for the Democrat
Party and you know one other thing going
back to the Virginia thing I meant to
say this before but as we see the
Virginia Democrat Party self-destructing
over you know and how it all began with
their push for late term abortion and
then we think about the State of the
Union address yes two nights ago
President Trump talking about late term
abortion and it was a big applause line
this just goes to show something that
I've been saying for years I've been
saying this forever which is that
abortion is a winning issue for
Republicans if they just had the
gumption to make the case it is a
winning issue especially when you talk
about later term abortion after 20 weeks
that kind of thing that is a winning
issue for for Republicans but they just
have to have the guts to talk about it
and bring it up and you know if you look
at the surveys and the polls you might
find that you know maybe it looks like
it's split or maybe there are slight
majority of Americans who consider
themselves pro-choice or whatever but
you also have to keep in mind that a lot
of those people they've never had the
pro-life case articulated to them they
don't know what it is they really don't
know anything about abortion they're
completely ignorant so if you just make
the case and you explain this is what
abortion is this is what the Democrats
want to do here's what's happening I
think that's a winning issue and maybe
Republicans are finally starting to
learn that I hope all right according to
that's I want to look at a story in The
Daily wire reported by Paul Bois it says
according to eater after nine years of
being a business Panera bread's
socialist pay-what-you-want restaurant
Panera cares will officially be closing
shop on February 15th due to the
business models unsustainability while
Panera cares
billed itself as a nonprofit restaurant
designed to feed low-income people the
business model is anything but rather
than create a charitable organization
the distributes food to needy families
or a discount outlet or even a $1 menu
like fast-food restaurants
Panera tried to create a socialist
system in which meals were offered at a
suggested donation price so basically
you could go into this Panera cares
restaurant and you could just pay
whatever you want you could pay more you
know or you could pay nothing and it's
sort of like an honor system set up and
now it's going out of business so on one
hand you look at that you think well it
was a noble effort nice try you want to
get Panera some credit for giving it a
shot
but I think this also shows you know
when you try to take a kind of socialist
mentality and apply it to and this is
you know you're very isolated controlled
environments just one Panera Bread
location right or maybe there were a few
of them I don't know but if that if that
system could work you think it would
work in that in that very kind of small
contained environment and if it doesn't
work there how in the world would it
work across an entire country of 300
plus million people well it won't and
part of this is you have to have and
this is something that the people on the
Left lack they don't have this but you
need to have an understanding of human
nature and if you understand it's not
about being cynical it's just about
understanding how people are and if you
have an understanding of human nature
you're going to realize well that a
system like that doesn't work you can't
have a restaurant people pay whatever
they want because most people if you
give them a choice they're gonna pay
nothing if you get most people a lot of
people anyway if you give them the
option of taking a free ride they're
gonna take the free ride that's just
human nature it's not about hating
people or thinking the worst of people
just about understanding how people work
so that's that one other thing before I
get to a couple of emails I want you to
watch this report now this was on
PBS this morning a report about climate
change pretty pretty typical kind of you
know fear-mongering over climate change
that you see but I want you to watch
this and look for some obvious flaws in
the reporting okay to watch this new
figures from two government agencies
show 2018 was the Earth's fourth warmest
year on record no other governments
weather agencies says global
temperatures were 1.4 degrees higher
than the average in the 20th century
NASA scientists say the rising
temperature trend is driven by increased
greenhouse gas emissions from humans the
past five years were the five warmest
ever recorded NOAA researchers say 14
weather and climate disasters last year
cost the u.s. more than 1 billion
dollars each hurricanes Michael and
Florence caused about 49 billion dollars
in combined damage Western wildfires
cost 24 billion all right so did you get
that every time you hear warmest year on
record so you're meant to be impressed
by that oh it's the warmest year on
record warmest year warmest year ever
and that's kind of what you're meant to
take those are well it's the warmest
year ever that the earth has ever seen
in fact sometimes you'll see it reported
with exactly that language warmest year
ever now the problem is that our records
only go back to the 1880s ok the earth
is 4.5 billion years old our records go
back to the 1880s so the sample size is
so minuscule and so tiny in comparison
to the age of the earth that it's just
meaningless
you can't possibly extrapolate anything
from it do you think about I think about
a hundred and you know whatever 130
years hundred and however many years
versus 4.5 billion years it's just how
could you possibly take anything from
that you need a much much much larger
sample size before you could justify
some sort of you know arguably that
there's some sort of crisis going on
the other problem and this is more of a
general thing but the next time somebody
frets over temperatures rising all you
have to do just ask them this and see if
they have an answer for it ask them what
do you think the temperature is supposed
to do okay so you're if you're worried
that the temperatures are going up
supposedly well okay what do you think
the global temperatures are do you think
they're just gonna stay exactly the same
forever do you expect to see global
temperatures not move an inch or a
degree over the course of a century is
that what you expect or should they
always go down well if they if they go
down then you're gonna tell us about an
ice age and I'm and I'm old enough to
remember when when they were fretting
about an ice age and now it's you know
and then it was global warming and now
it's just climate change in general you
see how they've they've changed it so
now it's just if the climate changes at
all one direction or another we're told
that that is apocalyptic well what do
you expect the climate to do of course
it's gonna change from year to year
century to century
it always has that's why I'm saying you
need the larger sample size look at 4.5
billion years of Earth history not just
not just since the 1880s and you're
gonna find that the temperatures are
going up and down drastically all over
the place
that's just what temperatures do that's
what climate does so in order to justify
the the this apocalyptic attitude you're
gonna have to tell us what do you think
the temperatures are supposed to do and
if you tell me that you think they're
supposed to stay static forever then I'm
gonna tell you that you just I don't
think you understand how climate works
all right let's look at a couple of a
couple of emails Matt Walsh show at
gmail.com Matt Walsh Oh gmail.com you
can if you have any comments questions
concerns and I try to answer a few at
the end of every show so this is from
Jerry he says hi Matt I heard that
you're not a fan of the KJV I've always
thought that the KJV was the best
translation available what is your
problem with it and what translation do
you prefer hi Jer yes the King James
Version we were talking about this on
Twitter yesterday which
assumes while you're bringing it up in
case you didn't know the there is a
group of Christians rather vocal
Christians who feel that the KJV the
King James Bible is the best translation
the only good translation available
there there there are KJV only
Christians is what how they're referred
to and most of them will say that well
it's the best English translation
available there are some KJV only ist's
who will actually tell you it's the best
translation period that exists even
better than like even better than the
original Greek but for the most part
they'll say what's the best English
translation and everyone has their own
preferences when it comes to Bible
translations and that's fine but to
insist that the KJV is the best even the
best English translation is absurd I
think it's not that I hate the KJV I
just I don't have any grudge against it
but the fact is that this translation is
one of the only translations in English
that has something called the Johanna
and , the Johanna and kama is an
interpolation which is in addition to
the Bible something that was not in the
original text and that was added into it
later sometimes centuries later so so
it's not biblical in that case so the
Johanna and kama is in 1st John 1st John
5:7 through 8 and in the KJV it says for
there are three that bear record in
heaven the father the word and the Holy
Ghost and these three are one now that
obviously is a clear reference to the
Trinity which is a true doctrine the
problem is that it's not an authentic
verse that that verse does not appear in
the earliest manuscripts and so pretty
much any New Testament scholar textual
critic that you read or listen to will
tell you that that is that's an
interpolation it was added into the text
later by some scribe some translator who
maybe was troubled by the fact that
there isn't a verse like this in the
Bible that clearly explicitly lays out
the Trinity now there are plenty of
places where the Trinity
implied but there isn't one verse that
lays it out exactly like that and so
there was some scribe and said well it
should be in there so we'll put it in
which you can't do that you can't do
that to the Bible you can't just decide
on your own that it should be in there
and so I'm gonna add it in so that's a
problem I think the KGB also has the
long ending of mark mark 16 9 through 20
is most likely a later edition according
to most scholars the earliest
manuscripts and the Mark's Gospel ends
with 16 8 where it says the women ran
from the tomb and told no one that's the
end of Mark's Gospel and then according
to most scholars it seems as though if
you look at the early manuscript it
seems as though somebody added in this
ending which again you can't do that
shouldn't do that shouldn't be in there
so the fact that that's in the KJV I
think really debunks notion that it's
the most accurate translation and then
also stylistically you know I just I
think the KJV style is great when you're
reading a lot of the Old Testament stuff
a lot of the prophetic books the Psalms
okay so that kind of poetic style I
think is great very beautiful in that
context but it is totally out of place
in the Gospels and the epistles because
Jesus and the Apostles these were plain
spoken men they weren't using flowery
language that nobody could understand
they were just speaking in the
equivalent of regular modern English
obviously they weren't speaking in
modern English but the equivalent of it
just regular plain spoken and so when
you add this flowery stuff into the
Gospels and you put it into Jesus's
mouth and you put it into Paul it I
think you just lose so much it's just
that's just not how these men
communicated because they weren't they
were talking to average people and they
wanted to be understood all right from
Mike he says your beard is awful real
men are clean-shaven
deal with it Mike that is nonsense of
course but I would expect nothing else
from a clean-shaven man saying that real
men don't have beards is like saying
real lions don't have Mane's or like
saying real Lumberjacks don't wear
flannel it just doesn't make any sense
but if you really want to get into this
fine okay let's do a comparison okay
let's do a scientific comparison let's
make a list of bearded men and compare
it to a list of non bearded men and then
we'll decide who comes out on top okay
so this is just a scientist a scientific
thing all right so I'm gonna just just
pulling names randomly a bearded men
just totally random Jesus Socrates
Leonardo da Vinci Grizzly Adams all of
the best Civil War generals Grant Lee
Jackson Sherman Paul Bunyan Gandalf
Lincoln all right now again just a
random list of unbeaten men Cory Booker
Jim Acosta Pol Pot Matt Damon all right
so I rest my case
let's see from John he says Matt I
listened to an interview you did with
Matt Fred if I remember correctly Fred
said that you do not believe pornography
can be addictive this struck me as odd
as I follow your show and writing
closely if this really is your take on
pornography can you please shed some
light thanks and love the show that's
true John I don't think addictive is the
right word I think this is a mistake we
make compulsion is a better word I think
it breeds compulsion I think the word
addiction is way overused in our in our
culture just like the word disease is
way overused and the problem is when you
when you use words like addiction and
disease in the wrong context number one
it has it has the the effect of
diminishing the severity of actual
addiction and actual disease and also
when you say someone has an addiction
when they don't really you're taking
some of the onus off of them and some of
the power away from them and when you
say they have a disease they don't
really have it as ease then again you're
taking away the choice and the free will
and the power that they actually have so
we need a way to distinguish I think
compulsive behavior from something like
heroin addiction when you use a word
addiction I'll keep that in mind okay
there's with heroin addiction there is
an actual chemical dependence that
arises where if
addicted to heroin you actually need it
in that if you just go cold turkey
without the help of doctors and you're
not in a facility and it's not being
monitored and you just decide I'm gonna
stop using heroin one day you could die
because your body your physiology
revolts against you it needs the
chemicals from the heroin so that's why
you need to be weaned off of it in a
controlled kind of way it's not like
that with pornography I mean you could
stop watching pornography and it's not
gonna kill you
nobody's ever died from pornography
withdrawal there in fact there is no
physical withdrawal that happens where
you're you know you be sits sick in bed
for days because you're not looking at
pornography and so which which isn't yes
there's a it is a real compulsive thing
but it's the same thing this is in the
category with something just like
watching TV there are people who watch
eight nine ten hours of TV a day even if
it's not pornographic television they
have a compulsion and it's a real
compulsion it can be hard to get past
it's very destructive I'm not
diminishing any of that but to compare
it to heroin addiction or to put it in
that same category or camp I think is a
big mistake finally last last one real
quick from someone who doesn't give a
name he says Matt I'm looking for
bourbon recommendations I hear you're
the expert what are your favorites well
I'm not an expert but I could tell you
my favorites my go-to at any at at a
kind of mid price range is for roses
single barrel me about forty dollars you
can go pick that up of course Woodford
Reserve is another one in that range
very good classic Knob Creek is a little
bit less expensive very good Eagle rare
is a little bit more expensive
excellent bourbon Noah's mill and
Blanton's in that same range as well
will it's if you're looking at a step up
you know in the sixty dollar area you
could go to will it's basil Hayden is a
great I think sort of entry-level
bourbon not because of the price about
forty bucks but it's a very smooth
unobtrusive bourbon which I don't like
as much as I used to but if you're not a
big bourbon drinker I would recommend
that and if you're just looking for
something cheap in the twenty to thirty
dollar range if you're looking for the
the the plastic twist twist top
sort of class of Bourbons then I would
say bullet you can't go wrong with
Bulleit Bourbon so there's my
recommendations go but go don't go buy
all of those at once they'll just start
speaking of addictions I would just
start with one at a time all right we'll
leave it there thanks for watching
everybody thanks for listening Godspeed